c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
il ya un recours que j'ai que vous vous
allez peut-être essayer de battre ce
soir même et s'ils arriveraient pour
s'assurer des flambées document g27
flamby est 60 secondes
allez-y christope il faut les bébés sont
évoquées dès la 30e jamais y arriver
attention il du top chrono ses banquiers
pour les plombiers et le chrono débarré
volet gober aux la perdez pas de temps
ça
je mange à côté du riz sauf qu ailleurs
en faute
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal combien la 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
10 11
merci je vous explique le problème le
problème c'est que là et on est censé
arrêter le happening mais comme c'est
gratuit il veut allonger d'autres c'est
un problème à les 10 secondes encore
christophe vous pouvez dix de plus
où et christophe merci de faire ça allez
les gars
[Musique]